you
[Music]
before kind of digging into what we did
I think especially kind of coming from
industry it's sometimes helpful to
motivate sort of like the actual
real-world problem that we're solving so
I'll tell you a little bit about like
what we use machine learning for ups
sorry but at least a subset to start
into kind of like motivate how we
approach these problems so if you're not
familiar with stripe we basically
provide a toolkit for starting and
running an internet business if you want
to run a business you usually want to be
able to like make money so a core piece
of that that was sort of the founding
piece of stripe is online payments and
rich api's for that and then we've built
kind of other complementary layers and
additions to help with things like
incorporation or fraud or with platforms
one thing that's interesting about our
use of machine learning is that it is
the case that our users are businesses
doing pretty critical stuff so you know
in some cases of machine learning maybe
you're like suggesting a recommendation
and if somebody doesn't like it well
they'll click on something else but in
our case we're kind of like operating on
you know many many businesses that live
in the real world and have real
customers and so we need to make a lot
of decisions quickly but also accurately
like sort of the worst case of machine
learning for us would be that we you
know accidentally shut down someone's
business or block all of their
transactions so that frames a lot of our
thinking about how we want to do things
for production in ways that are reliable
and reproducible and so a couple of the
ways that we're using machine learning
and our user facing products the most
prominent usage is in radar a fraud
product which is shown here or basically
every time you know you like order post
mates or do something with the stripe
user kind of in that charge flow we're
evaluating what is the likelihood that
that charge is fraudulent and blocking
it potentially if we think that it's
likely and also kind of giving users
some tools to kind of help manage that
or write extra rules another example of
machine learning for us is in our
billing product which is for you know
businesses that operate with
subscriptions and so we use machine
learning to help us
do you smart retries when a subscription
charge fails to kind of figure out when
or how to retry it so that it you know
it may go through for the business and
these are just kind of a couple of uses
of machine learning in our in our user
facing products we also use it machine
learning and quite a few places
internally for things like different
types of risk management or for other
things like suggesting resolutions for
customer support and things like that
and so now I'll tell you a little bit
about like how do we do model training
for these types of applications and
focus in a little bit on radar a fraud
product as the example there so this is
sort of you know a very simplified view
of what could be a training dataset for
evaluating fraud so each of the left
three columns are potential features
each row is like an observation and then
the rightmost column is the label these
are things like you know how much was
the transaction for what country was the
card issued in more complex kind of like
counter type features of you know how
many countries was this card used from
in the past 24 hours if you have some
credit card that's been used from like
seven countries in the past 24 hours
that's a little bit suspicious and so
this is this is kind of like you know
the type of data although a lot more of
it a more complex than this that we
might be using to train a model and then
you know basically what we wanted to be
like any machine learning problem it's
turn it into a matrix and like fit some
function to it on the right there's a
decision tree but it could be whatever
you want it to be and then you know try
and have something that will generalize
to whatever whatever inputs to use the
first and minus 1 columns to predict the
label column and then in the radar case
we are basically you know trying trying
to have really good outcomes for our
users and you know for example we have a
false positive then we may block a
legitimate charge or if we have a false
negative we may a lot about charge go
through and those are pretty bad
outcomes and then we always want to
measure our models as we do any training
process just the way you would for
anything maybe with some kind of
precision recall curve or ROC our AUC
and then we'll set
thresholds that we use if we're doing
something like blocking okay so
basically in kind of our early days of
working on these types of problems we
did training pretty pretty manually like
a data scientist or machine learning
engineer would maybe write some kind of
MapReduce or spark job or write a sequel
query they generate some park' data and
then they'd like you know imports IQ
learn or import extra boost in a
notebook and like put together all of
their data transformers and coders
serialize the model and manually deploy
it to production and basically as we
started to you know have sort of more
serious usage of ml in our production
systems and in particular really want to
automate things we kind of took a step
back to decide like really how should we
be doing model training so these are
kind of the requirements we came up with
we wanted it to be easy to get started
we didn't want to take that away from
people as often you know they're sort of
this question of like can I make them
all good enough that it's useful to use
in this product and we don't want to
make that harder one thing that was
really important was we wanted to be
flexible there's like a Cambrian
explosion of different libraries
frameworks you can use for machine
learning and we use a number of them
that's right like in addition to more
traditional things like scikit-learn
Etsy boost we use like pi torch fast tax
profit and we wanted to make sure we
could support this we want everything to
be automatable if we're gonna train like
hundreds or thousands of models every
day somebody you don't want someone to
have to sit around and kind of like kick
all that off and manage it as we've
grown more use of ml we realized the
importance of tracking and reporting
both things like kind of the data
lineage as well as just like you know
which team is that what are they doing
when did they do it did they got an
error and then I'm more like on the
infrastructure side we increasingly
wanted to make sure that everything was
reliable secure and then kind of taking
away the burdens of resource management
from people developing models at stripe
like people don't really want to think
about what instance type this thing is
running on
or you know kind of the details of what
they need they kind of just want stuff
to work as much as possible and so
basically the way we approach the
supposed to kind of break this into two
chunks I'll tell you about one that
manages more of like sort of the
usability requirements which we built an
API for which we call railyard and then
the other that manages a little bit more
of sort of our infrastructure side which
was basically kind of getting this to
run on kubernetes and so you know when
we were thinking about how can we make
model training better and have it usable
reliable reproducible early on we kind
of like taken people's training code and
put some CLI tools around it and made it
just like a little bit easier to do
common things like fetch features tree
models evaluate results but that's still
wasn't kind of going to scale to this
hundreds or thousands of models a day
that we wanted to do so we kind of look
to stripe itself for inspiration stripe
is kind of like an API company where we
make it really easy for users to
automate things like payments so this is
an example of the stripe API Docs which
is something that I think people really
appreciate about our product and we try
to kind of like learn from what striped
as well and so what we ended up with is
basically in thinking about the design
kind of breaking things into two pieces
to kind of give us this ability to
automate but also have a lot of
flexibility for users so we thought
about like should we have a DSL for
encoding components and specific
frameworks but that's kind of like you
know it's hard to get everything in
there you're constantly going to be
behind you're not gonna be able to keep
up with all the latest frameworks but we
did want people to be able to kind of
like easily automate which I'll tell you
more about as well so we ended up with
these kind of like a couple of
components where the model training
workflow is kind of like freeform Python
code where I'll tell you more but you
just kind of have to implement a tree
and function and then the part of your
request that you want to automate is
basically the the API request itself and
then that will reference the
floo and then really all right itself is
a Scala service so it has Jason and
points for training models for fetching
the results of model runs it kicks off
the training job and does the job state
management and basically like you send
it a post request and then you get back
a job ID that you can then get more
information about so here's an example
of what a workflow looks like and the
workflow is kind of like the contract
between railyard and your model where
you know we give the workflow some label
and feature data in points and the
workflow returns back the trained model
as well as the data sets that you used
and the workflow inherits from a parent
workflow class and then it just has this
one method here trained that you
absolutely have to implement and so this
is sort of an example of a minimum
Python and workflow for actually boost
and you can see kind of some of the
different parameters and that it returns
back the fitted pipeline the other piece
is the API request itself which has a
few different components metadata data
filters holdout data and training so the
request starts with the metadata that's
shown here which is really important for
us for tracking provenance of who is
training and what they're doing and
doing things like splitting out success
and failure metrics by team or by
perhaps individual and this helps us do
things like profile long-running jobs or
provide feedback
I should mention - I guess this API is
all the examples I'll show you are using
Jason but we also designed was proto
support in mind for in the future when
we migrate to G RPC for railyard the
next section here is like where you
specify your data the most important
thing is kind of like the path for your
features and where they come from which
in this case is Park a that in most
cases for us is something that's
generated by our features framework
which is a different interesting talk
when people are experimenting we also
give them an ability to specify this as
like a sequel query that can be run on
our data warehouse but that's
kind of more for experimentation then it
doesn't work as well for reproducible
production cases and then in the case
that you're gonna be like splitting out
your data set by date there's also the
date column shown here the next
component is this filters section and
this is sort of built around park' in
particular where we want to support
predicate push down and then we support
basic comparison and equality operators
some support for set membership and if
you want to do something more
complicated you can put it into the
workflow the next chunk is the holdout
data so this is just like how are you
separating your training in Tessa this
example is what the API looks like if
you're doing that by date but you can
also do things like random or stratified
sample in the case where you have by
date then there's also some parameters
to kind of specify what the date column
is on the start and end date and then
maybe most importantly the last chunk of
the API is the the training section for
the API request where you're going to
specify what is your workflow what are
the future names and that's in case you
kind of want to rewrite what those are
inside your workflow what is the label
column and then maybe one of the most
important pieces is this custom params
where just depending on what your model
type is people are gonna want to do
different things and automated on
different things and this has kind of
been like invaluable to us and there's
not a lot of requirements it just has to
be like a map string Jason so it just
has to be some kind of key value pairs
and the most common excuse we've seen
for this is hyper parameter optimization
which is probably something we're gonna
build first-class support into and the
API in the future but this this really
varies a lot and has been like a core
part of what's allowed us to support all
these different model types and
frameworks oops and so if you're the
user this is sort of like what your
interaction looks like where you you
know post to the Train on point with
your request what you get back is this
job ID and then you can check the status
of the request or you can fetch the
result and you can also automate these
into others
this's and then when we're looking at
the result here's an example of a
successful job that's been run and some
of the things you can see are like what
is the path for the logs which is pretty
important when did the job complete what
was the get Shaw so that we have you
know an idea what code was run what
where are the data for your holdout data
and labels which we then usually send on
to kind of our evaluation service but
users may also do other things with them
and then diorama ID is basically diorama
is our model prediction service so this
is the ID for the serialized model which
is the thing you can just directly serve
in production so we're kind of taking
care of that serialization and
persistence step in here as well and
then there's an exception info field
which here is null because this
completed successfully but if your dog
failed for some reason this will give
you a lot of information about why and
maybe a link to like the full arrow
trace back or something like a sentry
page let's see yeah and then one of the
key pieces for us especially for things
like radar where we want to Train like
many models on a regular cadence is that
these basic components give us the
ability to then add add additional
things into the system to automate so
one of the things we have is a
retraining service where you can specify
you know how often you want to retrain
and which model sets you want to retrain
for folks who train models in more of
kind of like a dag based workflow
setting we've also had people like
automate air flow tasks that call out to
railyard as well so a lot a lot of
different ways that people can kind of
build on these components we've given
them and then just stepping back I've
kind of told you about you know what are
the components we use on the training
data side but these do also kind of fit
together with a bigger system so as I
mentioned you know at the end of your
workflow you get like a model ID that
corresponds to a model package which is
how your she realized model is persisted
and then also at the end of your model
evaluation for each application like for
radar we have a tag and then
output of that will be sort of updating
the tag the model that you want to serve
for that tag which you know then we can
score with diorama are real time in
front service so everything kind of like
fits together nicely for for users so
just kind of from this part about how
how we design the API in workflow some
of the lessons we learned are on the API
being really flexible with what
parameters we let people input and we
found that not using a DSL was the right
choice for us and that would have been
too restrictive and also that tracking
model provenance is really important
especially when we have more users like
we do stop people kind of pop into the
team sock channel and say I don't like
my job Phil can you help me and then you
spend a long time tracking don't like
what code did you run where did you run
it and now kind of what if we have the
job ID we can figure out everything else
by ourselves or even kind of like
proactively reach out which has been a
big improvement and then on the workflow
side just kind of getting the interfaces
right I think was something that took a
little bit of work for us people will
load and transform their data in ways we
don't anticipate but having these
standard API interfaces like fetch data
pre-process training right evaluation
data helps kind of dictate some of the
serialized data containers that people
use while still being flexible about how
they're generated and then like I
mentioned kind of baking into the
smallest utilization and persistence was
pretty helpful since Emmel engineers are
data scientists like really don't want
to think about that they just want to
get out a model that can be served and
then similarly to tracking model and
provenance and ownership just like
measuring each step helps us understand
in debug and tell you know why is
training a model taking so long which is
something that inevitably comes up a lot
okay and so with that in hand I'll talk
a little bit more about more of the
infrastructure side where once we start
I've had a way for people to more easily
specify what they wanted to train and
train it you know we started we
initially ran that just kind of on
individual machines and then eventually
we realized we needed to abstract away a
lot of the complexity of that and also
make it just kind of like more reliable
reproducible and scalable and so we set
up all of us to run on kubernetes so
before before we had this basically the
situation was like a little bit dire for
people we had you know some number of
something like AWS instances that had
different properties like maybe they had
a lot of memory maybe they had GPUs and
you know people would kind of like
choose which one to run their training
job on sometimes maybe they get their
own box sometimes maybe they have to
share they didn't really know what else
was running on them and it was kind of
hard to tell you know will my job
actually work on this like I'm gonna
have to check in and see what someone
else is doing there was kind of like a
lot of coordination and a lot of
problems and this was true even even
after we had kind of like a training API
in railyard where we were running this
initially as kind of like a sidecar
service where we would parse the
requests and like execute the Python
process on the Boxter actually yeah so
this was a little bit unfortunate oops
and so by moving to kubernetes and using
that as the execution engine it makes it
a lot less likely that something will
run out of memory disk space CPU because
we can use communities to help us with
the resource allocation so that our
services is managing the job state and
the API endpoints but then it makes an
API request to kubernetes instead of
managing its own Python process which is
a big improvement this is kind of how it
works one of the key things for us was
figuring out like
how we would get the Python code
including all the dependencies that we
needed to run over to kubernetes and
what we did was we ended up using the
sub part library developed by Google for
a while stripe has been moving most of
our builds to the basil build system
because of its speed correctness
reproducibility and then its flexibility
to work in a multi language environment
and bezel works really well kind of out
of the box with subpar so this was a
good choice for us to help us bundle all
of our required pathan requirements in
source support code into a single par
file and basically with sub part you
define the entry point to your Python
executable and then basil builds the par
file that can be bundled into a docker
file and then with that you can also
package up like any third-party
dependencies you need like if you need
the CUDA runtime for GPU support for
your PI torch model say and then after
the docker image is built we deploy it
to for AWS the elastic container
repository to make it available for for
kubernetes to run and so basically if
you are user developing models your
workflow is you kind of like you know
iterate with your workflow and on your
branch during the testing and
experimentation phase and then you know
when you merge to master a new docker
image is built as part of the build and
then you can deploy that almost like
deploying code and then now your job is
kind of ready to be run on our
kubernetes cluster and one of the nice
things for us is that we have an
orchestration team that runs kind of all
of our communities clusters and so that
meant even kind of as a data
infrastructure team it took away like a
large a large amount of the burden of
sort of managing the underlying servers
and infrastructure and we got instead to
operate at a higher level of abstraction
just like interacting directly with the
kubernetes api this is kind of a picture
of what it looks like so clients
interact with the railyard API which
internally stores some state in Postgres
and then the scala service interacts
with the kubernetes api
and then you know we can start training
jobs on different resources very easily
and then from kubernetes we kind of pull
back the logs the serialized models and
the evaluation data and one of the
things you'll notice here is that
there's also different types of workers
like CPU workers GPU workers high memory
workers so I'll tell you a little bit
more about that as well so basically we
what we did was he added into our API
like a sort of top-level resource for
compute resource which makes it for
resource types that we've made available
kind of like a one-line change to get
get one of these different types of
resources that we've we've described and
so if you're a user you can just think
about CPU or GPU you don't have to think
about like p32 X large or a 3.16 X large
which are really hard to keep in your
head even if you know a little bit about
what instance types are like and then
basically internally we kind of figure
out for each of these resource types
like how to set the kubernetes what are
called toleration and affinity to help
schedule the jobs on the cluster that
kind of say like I would like to run my
job on this type of node or affinity but
don't run other jobs on my node which is
kind of the Toleration which works a
little bit like node tainting and then
we also as part of each instance type to
find a memory limit and a memory request
so there still is a little bit of trial
and error because we're not very
restrictive with what people can do in
their jobs to make sure that they're
gonna fall within the limits but it's a
lot easier to kind of have all of that
managed within kubernetes and to know
that you know at some point jobs will
get killed appropriately and that things
will be managed in general a lot more
consistently this also makes it a lot
easier for us to change the instance
types that maybe correspond to different
resource types or to just like expand a
set of like servers that we have in the
cluster that's that's a single command
instead of what used to be a lot more
work all right so that that kind of
completes the the second chunk
of like taking away the resource
management piece and making everything
reliable and secure and what we learned
here is the instance flexibility is
really important because different
machine learning workloads have really
different needs like we may run in one
day thousands of time-series forecasts
or a long running word embedding model
or a fraud model that's using hundreds
of gigabytes of data and just being able
to iterate and scale all of that really
quickly
has been really important for us as I
mentioned there is a little bit of trial
and error in figuring out how to set up
things like the memory limits and maybe
like reschedule failed jobs not
something that we're still looking at
using subpar works really well for us
because it integrates so well with Basel
and then just kind of finding this right
layer of abstraction for us as a data
infrastructure team where we no longer
have to kind of think at the cluster or
server level because we have a set of
folks who are managing kubernetes and
kind of provide the community's API to
us as a service has made us a lot more
efficient as an infrastructure team and
then I think it's always cool to see
like how things actually work so I just
want to kind of show you some metrics
from different dashboards of like what
would a user look at or like what
metrics do we track as an infrastructure
team so this is an example of the
dashboard from our model retraining
service so if you're a user and you know
you know that like all of your frog
models are about to kick off for the day
you can kind of check on the status here
and you can see some of them have
shipped which means the model was
trained and then the subsequent
evaluation decided that it was better
than the current model some of them you
know maybe failed like in this case
maybe there weren't enough examples of
one particular label and that training
set some of them are still running some
of them are not shipped where there is a
new model but it's not better than the
old ones so we're not going to put it
out we also train what we call
explanation models that are sort of like
simpler models that are a little more
interpretable see
sort of see what this looks like if
you're a user
we can track operational metrics so
these are things like you know how many
or what is the rate of successful
kubernetes job creations or how long is
it taking to create a community's job
and these are things we can also alert
on as an infrastructure team so if we
expect there to always be some jobs
getting started and there's a long
period where there aren't we can alert
and look into it without people kind of
having to file bug reports and ask why
training is broken so our users have put
together pretty pretty complex workflows
that do things you know like simulations
also and so we can break those out and
track track timing and errors as well
which tells them a lot about like where
things might be going wrong or where
they might want to invest their effort
and then just in terms of sort of the
scale or numbers we have you know like a
number probably dozens of workflows that
are set up using railyard for things
ranging from user facing products like
radar to payment optimization to more
internal facing applications like risk
management or customer support some of
the libraries we use are shown here
things like scikit-learn pi torch fast
text extra boost and profit every week
we train hundreds of thousands of sorry
in total we've trained hundreds of
thousands of models and we're training
thousands more every week we use
different resource memory types with GPU
CPU and high memory and then in the end
if you think back to kind of like the
full system picture I showed all of
these models that in the end come out
are used to make hundreds of millions of
real-time predictions every day and this
I think is like sort of an interesting
slide to show the impact of kind of all
of this on on the end users are ml
developers at stripe where you know for
a long time we did not train very many
models per week because people were just
kind of doing it by hand and it was a
lot of work and then as we gave people
an API and people started automating
things we started seeing these spikes or
suddenly there were a lot more models
trained but it's kind of buggy and you
know maybe driven by
one and one or two applications and then
as we kind of got rid of people having
to worry about the resource management
and like which box their thing was
running on or what instance type it
needed that's really helped us just kind
of scale up and how things go up into
the right in terms of like the
development that people are doing and
how that's going so here's here's sort
of a summary of all the things I've
talked about
we built a simple but flexible API for
running and automating training
workflows we do our resource management
in kubernetes we really try to
instrument everything along the way to
help us debug in profile and then
basically this is these are the systems
we use to train thousands of models per
week for this range of different
applications we have periodically Retton
like quarterly surveys of ml developers
at stripe which are really interesting
these are feedback so around the time
that we sort of ship this these are a
few of the comments we got so things
like you know really are just made it
much simpler to write any pipeline and
when my new teammate started I could
just point them toward docks to get him
going and people on my team were
relieved to hear that the training code
used a standard way of doing things so
they didn't have to just ask others how
to do it or this saved me time by
abstracting away the treat tedious parts
of training and letting me focus more on
building features and model architecture
so thanks for thanks for listening and
happy to answer questions I particularly
want to thank some of the folks on our
machine learning infrastructure team who
worked on this and you know if you or
anyone you know is interested in
interesting data rolls in here or in
Seattle or for remotes
using data to build ml products and
track and move money I'd be happy to
talk to you about that as well how do
you deal with the features which are
used in all these pipelines like they
would be like tons of features how do
users get those features yeah so that's
that's an excellent question which is
the talk into itself one of the things
we spent a lot of time working on the
past year or two is having like sort of
the
right abstraction for people to define
features where they only have to write
code once and it can be available for
training for batch jobs and for online
jobs and so that you can potentially if
it makes sense like share features
between applications and so we've done a
lot of work to kind of build a DSL for
that that has different compilers or
backends that can run like on spark for
maybe your training or on kind of like a
Kafka consumer set up for real time but
where the future code is the same and
that does a lot allow a lot of what you
said where you can almost like sort of
browse the features and be able to use
the same features in different models
which has been really powerful for us
especially since we often have like even
in the case of risk management there's a
lot of sort of related applications
where you might want similar features
and inputs um a few slides back you kind
of had your dashboard where you showed
failed shipped etc and you mentioned you
know the iterative process where you're
kind of comparing results of models and
then if it was not if it was better than
the other ones and it would ship so I'm
wondering maybe you don't always want if
it's something's better than the
previous model you might not always want
to ship it to production because it's
still something you're kind of
evaluating so how do you hold that
that's a really good question
and it's also something that's like a
little bit different for each
application and we're trying now to kind
of capture that more flexibly and sort
of like an evaluation API where you tell
us like what are the metrics you care
about and how they connect so in the
case of some of our applications people
do things like they want to say
something like maximize the recall at a
fixed false discovery or false positive
rate and if you meet that for any given
model which it might be some kind of
global model it might be segmented for a
user or particular users then that's
like ship it right and then the second
part of what you said maybe there's a
little bit of definition around like
what is ship it mean like are you going
straight out to production or how do you
manage that roll out so that's something
right now that mostly applications
manages themselves we're like usually
they'll kind of push the updated model
to almost like a candidate tag
and then do some kind of like feature
flag or a be testing or you know maybe
in the future and for some application
some kind of bandit but that's something
that eventually we kind of like hope to
offer a little bit more standardized
functionality as well um how do you
solve the problem of one job and
cannibalizing all the resource cpu ram
causing especially if it's over a
weekend it's causing deletes for other
jobs yeah so that's a lot better with
communities because you can do things
like set the parameters they give you
for this or things like this toleration
affinity of sort of like I want this job
to run on these nodes and don't run
other jobs there so it's not exactly one
to one but it gives you like a lot more
control and isolation for your
particular job like I mentioned we do
also have you know we set hard and soft
limits and sometimes people go over
those because we let them do like
basically arbitrary things so there's a
little bit of tuning around that that
overall I think the rate of like
something being killed because it's like
using too much memory is like pretty low
at this point
and so it's something that we're able to
work with more ease a lot more easily
than previously
how do you handle dependencies let's say
you have one of these embedding models
that somebody we trained and yeah
hundreds of other models depend on it
how does your API handle that yeah so
that's an excellent question and I guess
that that's mostly outside the API but
it's something that we deal a lot with
and so one thing that's maybe
interesting in this slide this diorama
ID that's a sha-256
so it's it's like sort of a hash of the
bytes and so we we have kind of like
this notion of immutable models so
anytime something is different you're
gonna have to update that sha and that's
one thing that keeps you from like
stomping over something else we also
have kind of what we call like a concept
of meta models where you can sort of
like compose different models so you
could have like model a either it
depends on model B or maybe it sells out
so maybe you have a case where it's like
you know use this model if there's not a
specific model for the user if there is
then shell out to that
all of that will be specified kind of
like using these immutable Shaw's so
basically that kind of prevents us from
getting in a situation where this thing
changed underneath you and you didn't
realize it and then the thing that's
mutable is just that AG - Shaw mapping
where the tag is your application so in
the end you say like you know radar
currently points to this Shaw and then
that Shaw may actually like shell out to
some number of other Shaw's as well
[Music]